[Music]
the main bad guy of the upcoming
Godzilla and Kong the new Empire movie
is none other than the red Kong the scar
King as his name is now revealed but
will he be alone as the only villain of
the show and yeah what drove him to this
state or how did he achieve such a
prominent status in the Earth so here in
this video we will dive down into what
we can infer from the synopsis and the
trailer and speak about his probable
Origins his size design and how he was
able to enslave the hollow Earth's gongs
so let's get to it let's begin with
talking about his size and design so as
we have seen in the trailer scar king
would definitely be a gigantic dude and
by the looks of him roaring at the
people in the beach he would be
comparable to Kong and Godzilla in size
some rumors say that he would be taller
than both Godzilla and Kong but that's
just what it is a rumor and we can't say
anything in relation to his absolute
height by looking at the scene of him
with the other Kongs in the volcanic
area but if we have to use our logic our
god-given Common Sense we would think
that he will be in a size range of 350
to 4 ft in height or 106 to 122 M why
cuz he has to have a size that is
intimidating enough to hold his own
against Kong cuz K's robust built would
be an advantage to Scar's lanky physique
therefore he has to be at least taller
to put up a good fight and be worthy of
being the main villain so what do we
know of Scar King's Origins well he is a
very old ape titan species an old
specimen and not the only one of his
kind since the young red mini Kong is
also hinted to be of the same species if
not a direct descendant one thing that
is for sure is that scar is from the
hollow Earth and has a different buil
and design as comp compared to the other
black Kongs scar has longer arms longer
legs and a crotch posture he also has
red fur which isn't a random genetic
mutation that is only attributed to him
because we also have the little red one
with the same fur coloration he also has
a longer face with a bald head
indicating that he might be old or his
species has that facial element the
baliness his ears are rounder than
Kong's while Kong has a more human
shaped ear scar King's ears are like
that of a monkey and lastly the enemy
Titan has shorter teeth than Kong well
at least relative to the head size the
canines the upper canines and the lower
canines are comparatively shorter than
Kongs so by all this comparison we can
say that scaring might be a subspecies
of Kong or red Kong that can communicate
with the other black Kongs and assert
his will upon them now this brings us to
the question as to how he became king
and what did he have to do to attain
this status in the hollow Earth so from
here on it's all theories and
speculations mind you but it's all based
on what the trailer has shown us it's
like joining the dots to see a pattern
okay scaring as to my own personal
belief has a long history pertaining to
the hollow Earth and there might be
scenes showing his past life this I can
definitely say will be shown to us
because gxk has updated the movie
synopsis their premise on the movie a
few months back was as follows the later
entry follows up the explosive showdown
of Godzilla and Kong blah blah blah
against a colossal undiscovered threat
hidden within our world challenging
their existence and ours okay but now
they have added another sentence which
says this epic new film will delve
further into the histories of these
Titans their Origins and the mysteries
of Skull Island and Beyond while
uncovering the Mythic battle that helped
Forge these extraordinary beings and tie
them to humankind forever so what I
think will happen is this scaring will
be shown in his prime way back in the
past trying to gain Supremacy over the
other Kongs the other Kongs of his tribe
as well as trying to subjugate the other
black Kongs as well this will lead to
the much discussed Titan war that will
drag in the goira species as well as
legendary stated that this film will
delve into the history of these Titans
and Adam wiard stating that in another
interview this movie will showcase an 8
minute long sequence featuring just
Titans without humans in it this might
mean that they would showcase how the
Titan war came to be and how scaring
gain his Supremacy by befriending
himself with another ancient Titan which
is shimu so this war will be devastating
eradicating the kingdom of the Kongs and
thinning out the Gojira population as
well and as to how he will gain an ally
in shimu well the devil is in the
details here remember the scene in a
trailer where they showed the skulls and
Skelter remains of many C Kong in a cave
I personally think that scaring will
begin kidnapping Kongs in the beginning
and sacrificing them to shimu as a way
to gain favor and when this deal is
sealed shimu will then begin to help him
in subjugating the other Kongs driving
them into submission and healing him as
the new ruler of the hollow Earth while
at the same time shimu will get his
regular K Cuisine this will drive most
of the remaining CS into Exile fleeing
their Hollow Earth home and ending up in
Skull Island this theory is also
supported by the synopsis as it said
that the movie will explain the origins
and the mysteries of Skull Island 2
which by now would be inhospitable due
to the storm brought about by chamot
destroying the habitat another important
clue supporting this theory is the
handprint seen in Skull Island during
the events of the 2017 movie The
handprint a scene by Randa and the
others was too big to be considered
belonging to a 100t tall juvenile Kong
so so it might be that scar King has
always known of the existence of Skull
Island maybe Time After Time coming to
the surface to hun down Kongs to feed a
hungry shimu and so this means that he
has always been active in the
monsterverse but we are only finding it
out now so is he more powerful than Kong
well that depends if by sheer brute
strength then Kong might have an
advantage here due to his more muscular
build but then again this depends on how
tall scar King really is so if they are
both the same size and Kong will be
stronger no doubt if scar is taller than
that might even things out a bit but
what about their power with weapons so
Kong has his ax and Scar is shown to
have a Whip made out of a Titan spine so
the range of this whip-like weapon might
give scaring an upper hand while Kong
throwing the axe might give him one up
to but that's just a single shot and
after seeing Kong's monster Affinity
Gauntlet the mechanical arm this means
that Kong might might lose the first
encounter with the red ape either losing
in a fair fight or gang up with shimu
help but this is yet unknown but I'm
leaning on towards the latter Theory
since Kong would have to seek out
Godzilla for assistance and also Kong
ain't no he won't ask for help to
deal with another AP problem he would
only do so if there's no other way and
if the world's balance is at stake so
lastly why would scaring attack the
surface World well there are three
reasons for that first Kong's encounter
with him would tell him that there is
yet another Challenger that might
Dethrone him and so he has to deal with
it and that humans in the surface needs
to be dealt with as well just as a lousy
lawn needs some trimming secondly the
little mini call might follow call to
the surface to escape the villain and
that both Kong and mini Kong might have
been targeted as the next items in shimu
menu lastly scar King might just decide
that his domain should include the
surface world as well and that Godzilla
must be taken out once and for all with
the help of shimu therefore establishing
his new Empire so if you like this then
watch this other one as well and do
check out our Channel as we might have
things that you haven't seen before like
subscribe and we'll see you in the next
video take care guys